cheese nips you asked for it stick
around to the end we love talking to you
guys enjoy this episode of spectrum and
I like the way of the old-school ways
work they did work we just messed it up
so that's important to you to be like
the breadwinner I'm the caretaker of
society
[Music]
my god this is a good question it's this
a normal thing to be worried about like
when you're growing up like you're like
am i normal you know like I hate this
when I was younger I was like wolves as
long as it's not but like eventually I
was like nah I'm fine I feel like this
whole conversation is just like bringing
to my awareness how impressionable and
like how much of our lives and our
masculinity is defined by when we're
kids when everybody's like oh you gotta
have a big dick you gotta have a big
dick and all you see is like only time
you see a dick is on porn and it's like
14 inches then it's like Owen Lang
doesn't look like ya then of course
you're gonna like start thinking about
it versus a changed my mind because what
he said was it made a lot of sense
because I remember the first time I saw
a porno and I saw a black guy his penis
I was like I'm not like that as I got
older I perfected my craft I've never
had a man has nothing to do with the
penis it's all about it's not the size
of the boats the motion of the ocean you
just love a woman you embrace each other
and it's just I've never had a problem
with a woman since then I think for
younger guys this is the concern that
I'm realizing is like maybe if these
discussions were more open about size
and whatever and that really over time
it all becomes okay and it's fine maybe
that would help a lot
[Music]
I like the way the old-school ways work
they did work we just messed it up so
that's important to you to like take
that leadership role to the tradition to
be like the breadwinner I'm the
caretaker of society I don't even like
seeing it this way once you give the
woman the power then you just
emasculated yourself I just I want to
stick to what's made me happy and my
grandparents my parents I'm just gonna
stick with it cuz it works it's not
perfect but it works be a man I think I
don't know I think we're just getting in
dangerous territory when we started
talking about chivalry at the end day
it's like yo baby if you want to pay for
this like there is no hierarchy here
like if you want to pay for this pay for
this and maybe next time I'm like I just
got a check so I'll pay for it
wasn't this the first meal though you
say the first time you want to get one
chance to make a first impression what
does it matter if it's a girl or a guy
it's 2019 and your logic shouldn't be
like no disrespect like oh because my
grandpa did it and it worked for him
then it works for me if she's not gonna
date me that second time cuz I didn't
pay for her I think I dodged a bullet
[Music]
be real be real at first when I saw it
you know and talking to my friends a lot
of family a lot of people in the south
they're like these women should have
spoke up a long time ago and then I had
to like step aside and really process it
for myself and be like you know what she
didn't feel comfortable and it wasn't it
and she wasn't in a society in a place
where it was acceptable for her to say
anything about it so now that they have
the platform and the ability I'm like
that's amazing speaker truth what do you
tell a child who is accused of rape by a
woman has his whole life destroyed and
then people just go yeah there's always
gonna be people that take advantage of
it it's not gonna be perfect we're
figuring it out as we go but I think
it's done more good than it's done bad I
think I think we get to acknowledge the
bad though like I feel like worse that's
why I'm doing like this thing is like
for us to say like oh he did that to me
and all of a sudden now we've like
vindicated that guys like vilified like
there is no chance of like him having a
say in the conversation trying to
politicians are not good like this mob
mentality is bad I agree with that but I
don't think that's exclusive to the me
to movement but we're using it right now
to say oh that person is bad oh [ __ ]
that person there's no further
conversations being happening if it's a
movement to say yes
okay this hierarchy we've created of men
and women which is a result of the way
men are expected to act that women are
expected to act let's have those
conversations and everything changes and
I'll be over there all [ __ ] day
[Music]
you use a different word yeah yeah I
think I just someone agreed that its
blown out of proportion because I think
what happened with social media is a
group of people coin a term and now it's
we're all painted by it like we are not
in like a post I don't know like rape
culture world you know like women are
being catcalled every day and so like
men are still I think seen or
experienced as like a predatory presence
to women so like that's why I just don't
think it's like overblown I think it's
just its new if we were good men there
wouldn't be feminists they wouldn't be
attacking us they wouldn't be hating us
you have a lot of guys who don't want to
commit to marriage you have a lot of
guys who cat call so yes men have become
toxic and once again I have to be I have
to be consistent with all my beliefs and
all my morals I'm very traditional I see
what you're saying but the way you're
framing it like this this word moral is
kind of we don't know what that is
anymore though that's the well it's like
it sounds like you're saying like it's
men's job to be like the moral compass
of society mmm it is I think it's it's
everybody's but man if men want to coin
themselves as the leaders you have to
hold up is a good and the best part of
the problem though like that's what I
think toxic masculinity or it's putting
too much pressure on yourself I mean
it's very obvious that we're grappling
with like the history and the damage of
like what a world completely run by men
does to us that's why I think we're
talking about toxic masculinity
[Music]
it's been like harped upon me for years
that like showing my emotions were bad
and like me trying not to be gay I'm
like no like I don't want to show these
emotions cuz I'm not gay I can't be gay
like I'm not supposed to be gay like the
church tells me my dad tells me my mom
tells me everybody's telling me I'm not
supposed to be gay so like just
understanding that at 25 now 26 like I'm
over here like okay like oh you're
insecure okay that's what that feels
like
oh you're sad that's what that feels
like I can now be aware of those things
but to show them to other people right
now is like really hard for me I do feel
like I'm very verbally like about my
emotions with my wife but I wouldn't
agree completely because I'm not like
that with anyone else I mean I just
filled a college class and I was crying
about it to my wife but no one else at
school saw me cry
you know I specifically texted my wife
make sure the kids are asleep by the
time I come home cuz I just knew I was
gonna be like as soon as I stepped
through that threshold to my house I was
just gonna let go and I didn't want them
to see that but like the next day I sat
down and I had that conversation with
them like hey I just wanna let you guys
know you know your dad didn't pass this
class and they're like are you okay and
of course she's no crying in front of
your kids Ben I remember like seeing my
dad cry for the first time when his mom
died and I remember like imprinting that
in my mind as like wow you know like my
dad can be upset and that was like a
important thing to witness it's reality
emotion yeah it's real I was raised by
two parents that I never ever saw cry
the effect that that had on me was by
the time one of them passed away very
suddenly I didn't really seem to be
affected at all so I've actually had to
do a lot of therapy on
this thing about masculinity not being
able to show your emotions is very bad
it puts us backwards in society and and
we need to be thinking about how to tap
into our emotions in a healthy way
together yeah we love having this type
of dialog I'm grateful because as a girl
I'd love to know what you guys are
thinking you guys are mysteries to me
honestly make sure you like subscribe
and follow us on Instagram yes it's a
grub we'll see you next time
[Music]